hi everyone my name is
abi sudarshana and i'm
a first year biomedical engineering
master's student
at uc irvine and i recently just joined
the research fellowship here about two
weeks ago
so i'm excited to be here and learn
more about bioinformatics so today i'll
be going over
a course that i finished called tca
biomedical data visualization in r
specifically for rna sequencing so
i'll be going over that
so first of all as an introduction rna
sequencing
is basically obtaining the genetic
sequence of rna transcripts
which tells you about the gene
expression
so this basically tells you what genes
are being expressed
at a particular point in time
in a cell so rna sequencing is used to
understand
different cell types and it can tell you
at what level genes are being expressed
in cells whether
lower or higher expression and that can
tell you about the phenotype aspects
about cells
and different cell states and we can
identify
characteristic gene expression patterns
for specific cell types
and cell states so that's why rna
sequencing is important
and typically sequencing is done using
next-gen sequencing so we can do high
throughput examples
of rna and there are common steps
in the rna sequencing analysis workflow
which is listed here so first of all we
have to
do the processing of reads that are
coming from sequencing so these reads
have to be
cleaned up and pcr duplicates
have to be accounted for and removed and
the adapters on the ends of reeds
have to be removed so all this
pre-processing needs to be happening
before you can really analyze this data
and then
once the reeds are cleaned up and ready
to go we do
alignment to a reference genome so this
basically tells you
where the transcript the sequence is
coming from
in the genome what genes is that
corresponding to
and also you can see what type of
variants exist
meaning that where the sequence is not
completely
similar to the reference genome and
there are certain changes in
the dna basis and then from this
after the alignment we can get the gene
expression
quantification and then from then we can
understand
what genes are being expressed and at
what levels they're being expressed at
so these are all so this gene expression
quantification leads us to
the different types of analysis that we
can do on this data
so first of all there's exploratory
analysis which is basically
getting the fundamental aspects of the
patterns understanding them across
different temples
and we can make basic comparisons and
then data mining
is how we can separate groups
of samples by gene expression
based on the variety of genes that
exist and then after that by using
certain machine learning tools we can do
feature selection which is essentially
saying
we can select genes that are very
important
in discriminating between different cell
samples
and in this case in this course we
looked at
how genes could help differentiate
between different
clinical subtypes of cancer
and also lastly the classification
aspect
of machine learning as using
pca in this course where
we can essentially help cluster these
samples based on gene expression
into their different cancer stuff types
so from the data we get after cleaning
up the sequencing reads
we get a gene expression table that we
could generate after doing some
basically quantile normalization um
those techniques that are mentioned
so essentially we can normalize the
reads
so then they're comparable to each other
so the expression values
in the table seen here is of
63 breast cancer cell lines which are
the columns
and the rows are the genes and the gene
expression values
after normalization and processing is
shown here as well so this is just a
snippet of the
data table so
in this data table we can see that the
genes
are as in the rows and the columns of
the breast cancer cell lines
however for the principle component i'll
analysis
approach the pca we would actually want
to transpose this matrix and have
the rows be the samples and the
columns be the genes so that we can
essentially get a set of genes
and the columns that help separate our
samples
and cluster them appropriately so we'll
see that in the next slides
and why we want to have genes as
problems
and also from this pca analysis
we can see how each gene contributes to
the classification of these cancer
subtypes to some degree
so i'll go into pca just a little bit
briefly go over this
approach so pca is essentially a
principal component analysis which is a
dimensionality reduction technique
that transforms columns in the data set
to
a concise new set of features
and we're essentially finding new set of
directions
or components that explain the maximum
variability
between samples so this these principal
components
are essentially ways to condense the
data that we have
in the columns and represent them on
a more lower dimensional space such as a
two-dimensional space as shown in the
graph there
so we can take many different features
and then select these components
that help explain the variance in most
of them so
they can tell us the most information
that exists in the data set
and this helps us in clustering the data
into different samples based on
the specific genes that exist so the
steps in pca are
essentially we use different
weights for each column that's why we're
using genes as the columns
and we use different weights and
calculate those
based on the variance as explained and
we do scaling of columns and
there's those type of small steps in
between here
and then the principal components
are given in a scree plot which
basically shows
how the level of variance explained by
each principal component
so each principal component
is essentially a linear combination of
the columns
in the data set
so there's highest to lowest principal
components
in the percentage of variance they
explain so the first principle component
pc1
would be the most important or most
informative principle component
that gives you information about the
data
so here in this course we had an example
of multiple genes and the samples
that they corresponded to and
here if we know what
clinical subtypes the samples are from
the different cancer subtypes then
we can do a supervised approach to pca
which is we can label these samples and
then
we can see what genes most contribute to
the classification
of those different subtypes so here we
see the graph
where pc1 pc2 so principle component one
principle component two
um is shown because principle component
one and two are the most
informative and they capture most of the
variants of the data and to help
optimally separate the clusters
so pc1 is 53.5 percent of the data that
is explained
so similarly pc2 it's what it means
and then in the clusters each cluster
belongs to a specific subtype as shown
and labeled so from here we can see the
arrows the loading arrows which show
where i show how certain groups of genes
contribute to the classification of that
specific cluster
so there are gene labels shown
starting with ensg and those are the
individual genes that contribute to
classifying those individual clusters
and from the data we can also extract
the most the genes that most contribute
to
clustering of different samples and so
that we can basically
take the most 10 most important or 15
most important genes
from the data set and say that these
genes are
more indicative of this
sample being a certain cancer subtype
so that was basically just a brief
overview and review of how rna
sequencing data
is analyzed and different approaches
such as machine learning can be used
and rna sequencing gene expression
can be used to understand different
cell types and understand gene
expression profiles better
and we can see how gene expression and
certain important genes correspond to
certain
clinical subtypes of breast cancer and
pca
is an important machine learning
approach that can be used to reduce the
dimensionality and help
easier help easily visualize
and better cluster and classify data in
an unsupervised
unsupervised way where you don't know
the labels if you don't know which
subtypes
exist or a supervised way where you can
initially label these subtypes
so we can understand the most important
genes in classifying cell types
from pca and there are other methods to
optimize
the classification of these
cell samples into subtypes which is
using random forest
algorithms to get
understand you know better most
important genes
in classification and also the k-means
algorithm
which is using a clustering method
to cluster samples together that are
most similar
thank you and i look forward to
continuing
learning more in this program